kid did you ever love me I didn't stay
home making Apple brown Betty's no I
made you a champion knowing you'd hate
me for it that's the sacrifice that
mother makes well Allison Janney uh
might as well clear our schedule dope
for Mark support because she is gonna be
at the Academy Awards I mean she's got
to be a lot to get a nomination so
talented she's unbelievable in a Tonya
and Carly Steele found out how Allison
became so good at playing someone
portrayed skated like a graceless was
embarrassed for you I think that's that
was my challenge with this role is to
find where her wounds were what pained
her in life and bring that out stop that
Allison masterfully transformed for the
role of Tonya Harding's mother Levana
replicating her unique look Byrd and all
how was working with that parrot were
you worried you would get nicked and
that you never work with birds and I'm
an animal person I love animals but I'd
never never been a bird person because
they kind of freaked me out a little bit
I was intimidated and I was determined
to not let it get in the way of telling
my story and that bird was one of my
favorite animal acting partners ever
Allison says starring in this movie
changed her mind about the real Tonya
Harding I used to be a figure skater
myself so I was very aware of the world
of figure skating we were fed a lot of
the Tonya and Nancy news story and it
was all pretty much Tonya bad Nancy good
and we ate it up Allison and Tonya met
for the first time at the movies
Hollywood premiere so what are you going
to talk to her about just tell her how
much her story is unique and remarkable
and kind of inspiring in some ways
really all I really want to do is hug
her
[Music]
you